in the Seven Kingdoms of Westeros the
dominant religion is the faith of the
seven first brought to its shores by the
and I'll some 6,000 years ago but there
are some who still keep to the old way
worshiping the faceless gods of the
children of the forest in the first men
the old gods are countless nameless
spirits of nature and ancient times the
children of the forest carved faces in
the trunks of the weirwood trees which
became sacred symbols of their faith in
time
first when adopted the children's gods
as their own most castles at that time
contained a godswood with a wayward or
heart tree at its center meanwhile
across the Narrow Sea a new religion was
born in the hills of and Alice according
to legend the god of seven revealed
itself to the Andals and the invasion of
Westeros followed soon after the and
Isles sailed across the sea on ships
armed with weapons of Steel some
warriors carved a seven-pointed star
into their skin as a symbol of their new
faith invaders destroyed most of the
weirwoods in the Southern land
slaughtered the children of the first
whatever they could find and conquered
every Kingdom of the first may save the
North in time faith of the seven spread
like wildfire throughout the land the
seven is a single deity with seven
aspects each symbolizing a different
area of life that most people refer to
the seven as separate gods
the mother is prayed to for mercy and
watches over fertility childbirth and
peace the father sits in judgment over
Souls the warrior is prayed to for
protection valor and skill in battle the
chrome is the symbol of wisdom and
foresight the Smith watches over
creation and craftsmanship the maiden
symbolizes purity love and beauty
finally there is the stranger rarely
pray to who represents death the faith
is highly organized and deeply
influential in Westerosi politics and
culture as the official religion of the
monarchy worshipers gather in temples of
the faith called sets the seat of the
faith is the great Sept of Baelor which
is located in the capital city of King's
Landing still in the North were
descendants of the first men dwell
worship of the old gods continues to
this day
in the sacred faces of the weirwood
trees he close watch over the faithful